Stanford, and Stanford GSB's
executive education program has
a very distinctive philosophy
of leadership education.
We really think that the best leaders
blend the analytical and the intuitive,
our program is really good at giving you
strengths and both of those dimensions.
One of the most powerful things about our
programs is the ability to rethink your
challenges and rethink your problems and
call back to your organization.
And help people in your
organization think about and
approach their challenges
really differently.
Here in Stanford, we believe that
who teaches you really matters.
I think that's really the secret sauce,
is that we have these scientists, right?
Who are going to help you
think like a scientist.
They're going to help you
break down your problems and
think about your problems
in a different way.
Oftentimes, leadership is lonely.
You have problems in your organization
that you can't solve by talking to
people in your organization.
One of the most valuable things you
get out of an executive education
program here at Stanford is
a group of fellow participants who
have been through the same experience.
They've developed the same language.
They have the same frameworks, and
they can become your trusted
advisors going forward.
Joining an executive education program
it's a big investment of time and
resources.
What I can tell you is that everybody
I've met who's made that decision and
has come to Stanford and gone through
our programs has been transformed.
My hope for people who come through these
programs is always that they leave.
[MUSIC]
Thinking differently about themselves,
thinking differently about their jobs,
thinking differently about
their organizations.
And most importantly thinking
differently about how they're going to
change the world.
[MUSIC]